Hoy vamos a hablar aquí en la pizarra de Quintana de los jugadores más infravalorados
de la Liga española. Un tema que siempre da mucho que hablar, que siempre es muy interesante,
porque claro, ¿qué es estar infravalorado? Claro. Depende de cada uno, de sus entornos,
de sus expectativas. Yo os he pedido, chicos, que me hayáis hecho caso, eso ya no lo sé,
pero yo os he pedido que busquéis nombres que estén infravalorados en la opinión pública,
porque al final nosotros hablamos mucho entre nosotros y va a ser difícil sorprendernos,
porque no es que tengamos criterios parecidos, salvo en el caso de Adrián Blanco y Servidor,
pero sí que hablamos tanto de los mismos nombres que es raro que nos vaya a sorprender. Pero es
verdad que luego hablas con amigos, quizás no tan futboleros, hablas en otros foros de debate y
demás, y hay jugadores que pasan muy bajo el radar y que nos llama la atención porque vienen
destacando. Buscamos a esos jugadores, básicamente. Yo ayer para hacer el ejercicio fui abriendo
plantilla a plantilla los 20 equipos de la liga para no saltarme a nadie, para que no se me olvida
a nadie. Y me costó encontrar. Me costó encontrar jugadores que diga, está infravalorado. Quizás
sea porque estamos muy acostumbrados ya a verlo. Estamos demasiado acostumbrados. Claro, sabemos
cómo juegan, sabemos qué pueden dar. A mí me cuesta más encontrar jugadores sobrevalorados.
También es un ejercicio complejo. Es un ejercicio que haremos, pero me cuesta más. Si queréis,
empiezo con el nombre que me llevo a decir, oye, vamos a hacer esto, que tampoco es… Esto lo
hacemos recurrentemente. Cada dos, tres años siempre hacemos algo de este estilo. Para mí fue
Sergi Altimira. O sea, viendo Altimira… No digo que esté infravalorado entre la afición del Betis
porque creo que la consideración es buena, pero creo que es un jugador que juega realmente bien
al fútbol, que entiende muy bien la posición, que puede encajar con diferentes perfiles y me parece
ese típico centro campista del fútbol español con una gran percepción del entorno, con una gran
salida de balón, que sabe jugar, que quizás no tiene el físico más dominante y por eso quizás
tampoco llama tanto la atención. No es un jugador de highlight, pero es que juega muy bien al fútbol
y me parece que está infravalorado claramente. El tema es que yo creo que Altimira… Bueno,
para empezar es un fichaje de perfil muy bajo. Sí, el remontó en su día. Además, muy claro.
Lo hemos robito a la Getafe. No llega a debutar con la Getafe. Sí, sí. Y yo creo que sobre todo en
Altimira ha habido un crecimiento reciente, que creo que es lo que hace que esté infravalorado. Creo
que su temporada pasada es muy buena, que ha empezado muy bien esta, pero que es un jugador
que tampoco decía mucho. Sí, pero a mí por lo general es que me gusta. Me parece un jugador… Es
que lo que hace lo hace todo bien. Yo creo que pasa mucho que cuando tú ves a un jugador por primera
vez, más o menos haces una idea del jugador y esa idea es muy difícil moverla. Y creo que Altimira
ha tenido un crecimiento que nos planteemos para cambiarla. Exactamente. No obstante,
el rey de esta categoría es un compañero suyo que juega en el Real Madrid-Bolombia.
Altimira. Sí. ¿Quién? El rey de los infravalorados de la Liga, Saito Ruival.
¡Uy! Sí, sí. Me gusta. Ruival está muy infravalorado. Sí, sí. Sí. Yo creo que todo el mundo
tiene muy claro que Ruival… Ha aprendido a valorar su rol de equipo. Eso estoy agrediendo.
A mí me parece mejor futbolista de lo que… Hombre, un jugador que es capaz de hacer las
posiciones y que te rinde bien. Claro. Pero yo creo que no es una cosa… Yo creo que no es
una cosa de Ruival como tal, sino de ese tipo de futbolista. Estoy de acuerdo. De ese tipo de rol.
El perfil. Que no valoras el jugador que dices no es un fenómeno, no son fogos artificiales
constantes, pero que siempre te aporte y siempre te complementa lo que ya tienes en el equipo. Yo
creo que por ahí hay muchos jugadores de ese perfil que tenemos que infravalorar. Suéltate
un hombrecito. Alex de Llano. Yo tengo uno que además es internacional con España. Pero me
parece que está… Y está infravalorado. Para mí sí. ¿Ha sido recientemente internacional?
Recientemente. Es que yo en mi lista tenía Jorge de Frutos antes de ir con la selección. Pues no,
el mío no era Jorge de Frutos. El mío es Daniel Vivian. Me parece que está muy infravalorado
respecto a su rendimiento. Es el central y capital general de la mejor defensa de la temporada pasada
en la Liga y creo que ninguno te lo hubiera incluido quizá en el mejor once de la temporada
pasada en la Liga. ¿Sabes lo que influye en esto muchas veces con el espectador sobre todo que vea
a Vivian? Pues si eres madridista pues en el Madrid Athletic. Lo ves también contra el Barça,
a ver si tal. Pero lo ves en pocos partidos. Que con la selección ha tenido altos y bajos.
Sí. Ha tenido momentos de lucimiento. Bueno, como hay torparedes quizá, ¿no? Que es un poco…
Pero ha tenido otros momentos más complicados. Pero a mí me parece un nombre…
Yo creo que la Vivian ya está más… Pero yo no sé si entre nosotros.
Yo creo que es entre nosotros. Yo creo que… O sea, ahora mismo te vas a…
Si tú preguntas. Dame una lista de los… Dime, los cinco mejores centrales de la Liga.
Casi ninguno te meta Vivian. Sí, estoy de acuerdo.
Yo te diría que del Athletic, que creo que tiene unos cuantos,
el más infravalorado me parece a Iñaki Williams. Que creo que es la eterna constancia,
que es un futbolista tremendo. Me encanta. Creo que ha sabido cambiar un poquito su
narrativa en el Athletic desde aquella del nueve fallón. De que otra vez parecía que era todo…
Muy bien. …mucho pesimismo. Que iba siempre con la nube encima.
Y creo que es un futbolista tremendo. Ya en esta temporada con capitanía incluida. No sé.
Me parece que no hablamos lo suficiente de Iñaki. Yo a Iñaki hace unos años…
El hecho de que exista Nico creo que también le quita mucho foco también.
Claro. Sí. Yo hace unos años…
Sancet. …cuando no… Cuando todavía no
estábamos ni siquiera en Radio Marca, cuando tenía el canal en YouTube, recuerdo hacer un vídeo de
Los Incomprendidos, donde yo metía, por ejemplo, a Koke, que me parece que se ha enfravalado mucho,
pero sobre todo por incomprensión. Y metía también a Iñaki Williams,
precisamente por ese hecho. Yo de la Athletic Club iba a citar a Ruiz de Galarretta. Me parece…
Sí. …metrónomo total. Creo que la gente de
la Athletic Club lo valora top. De aquí buscamos, insisto, no que le
infravaloren sus aficionados, sino que se infravaloren fuera. Y claro, brillan tantas
cosas en Athletic Club que entiendo también que esa pieza más de continuidad, más de hacer jugar
al resto… Pues no…
Es un caso… …no ocupa tantos circulares.
…ciertamente parecido al de Altimira en el Betis. Cuando ves a Athletic Club…
Es un perfil parecido. …se te van los ojos a otros
jugadores. Seguramente más a Jauregui Zalona en Athletic Club porque llama más la atención que
Galaxy. Yo tengo a un… Hablabas antes de Jorge de Frutos. Tengo un compisubio en el Rayo.
Álvaro. No, a Pep Chavarría.
Ah, mira. Sí.
Ah, muy bueno. Creo que está bastante infravalorado.
Pero este es de explosión. Sí. Tardía.
Tardía, ¿no? Y creo que está…
Un último año y medio, stop. Brutal. Brutal. El lateral izquierdo,
para mí, inesperado. Pero cuando el Rayo ficha al Pachaspino, pensaba que el Pachaspino se iba
a comer el lateral y iba a ser ese futbolista. Y poco a poco a lo bajín y, como diría Iñaki
Williams, creo que Pep Chavarría se ha hecho con el hueco y muy bien.
Yo es que creía que ibas a citar a Álvaro. También lo tenía aquí porque hemos hablado
durante mucho tiempo de Issy Palazón y menos de Álvaro. Y la mayoría de jugadas que empezaba
Issy las acababa Álvaro. Y ha continuado. Y va a batir el récord de más goles en previsión.
De Alberto Bueno. Que es de Alberto Bueno, exactamente.
Fue el primer goleador en… en… Conferenz.
En Conferenz. Está en todas las fotos históricas del Rayo Vallancano a nivel
contemporáneo. En los últimos cinco o seis años está.
Y es un detalle. Veis que incluso aquí Andonir Aola nos lo vino a reconocer cuando le entrevistamos.
Antes incluso de debutar con el Bournemouth. Le preguntamos ¿Oye, esto que se ha publicado
sobre que querías llevarte Álvaro García es verdad? No recuerdo si no lo reconoció explícitamente,
pero admitió que era un jugador muy bueno, muy valioso. Y creo que ese tipo de jugador quizás
más valioso para el entrador que de los que entran por la vista. Por cierto,
uno de los mejores definidores de primera división en el mano a mano.
¿Qué más nombres tenéis? Mira, es que hay mucho perfil rival. Creo,
por ejemplo, lo de Rafinha es eso a otro nivel. Sí, pero Rafinha no. Yo creo que no está infravalorado
ahora. Ahora no. Yo había pensado también en Diego López en el Valencia. Me parece clarísimo.
Yo de verdad no entiendo… ¿Pero por qué se infravalora Diego López? Tengo
la sensación incluso de que a este sí me gusta más a mí que al valencianista.
A mí me parece un futbolista completísimo, muy adaptado al fútbol moderno además.
Pero que hace cifras además. Sí, un delantero en banda, pero con
velocidad extremo. A mí me parece un futbolista top y que me sorprende que no llame a su puerta,
más a mí me acuerdo de todo viendo lo que cobraba hasta hace mes y medio.
De hecho, cuando llama Luis de la Fuente a Jorge de Frutos, yo pensé inmediatamente en
Diego López porque es un perfil muy parecido y que ha estado en dinámica de sub-21, que sabemos
que esto para la selección, para Luis de la Fuente, es muy importante,
el subir peldaños en la escalera del fútbol formativo español.
Sí, sí. Diego López era un cracazo y, bueno, si sigue esta progresión vamos a verle mucho
tiempo jugando a competiciones europeas y quién sabe si es la selección.
Yo tengo uno que es Fran Beltrán. Para mí es un jugador que debutó muy joven en primera división,
que tuvo que hacer ese salto de rayo a Celta de Vigo.
Debuta en segunda, ¿no? Debuta en segunda, eso es. Y luego
terminaba marchándose al Celta y para mí es un futbolista infravalorado ¿por qué? Porque creo
que el Celta de Giralde no lo podríamos entender en las mejores noches o en los grandes partidos
sin Fran Beltrán. Creo que es ese futbolista que le maneja, que además tuvo goles importantes.
Me gusta un poquito menos que a ti. ¿Te gusta menos?
Un poquito. A mí es que me gusta mucho.
O sea, no me disgusta, pero no… A mí es que me parece que es un futbolista
que además ha encontrado en Giralde. Yo creo que es un entrenador que le entiende.
Porque él es un futbolista de mucho movimiento, de estar constantemente hacia arriba, hacia atrás,
hacia arriba. Es un medio centro raro.
Es un medio centro rarete. Y al final los medio centros raretes son los que le están
gustando más a Claudio Giralde, que por eso ha sacado a relucir también a Ilaich.
Yo tengo otro centro campista más llegador que Fran Beltrán, polivalente, que es Pabgay.
Le tengo. Muy bueno.
Me parece que está bastante infravalorado este tipo.
Totalmente. Muchas más cosas de las que parezcan
simplificadas. Creo que ya ha explotado… O sea, en la oferta de Arabia que se hablaba,
el partidazo de la primera jornada empieza a… Llamar la atención.
Claro. Pero ya el año pasado… En otras temporadas el nombre del Villarreal
que entraba aquí muy bien era el de Parejo. Sí.
Creo que ha sido un eternísimo infravalorado. Sí.
Y luego del Villarreal tengo otro, que es Juan Foit.
Me parece que Juan Foit está infravalorado. No sé.
Yo creo que sí. Cuando empezó a sonar para el Barça…
Todo el mundo la acoplaba. Yo creo que sí porque además recuerdo
grandes partidos ante Vinicius… No sé. Creo que no está del todo…
Te diría que me suena alguno ante Canmar también, pero no sé si ha sido tanto.
Sí, fue… Yo creo que no.
No, fue Seleccionado. Fue en los talbamos. Yo sí que creo que está valorado…
Yo a mí… No sé.
A ver, claro. Hay que ver dónde ponemos la vara.
No, no. Es muy difícil. Es muy difícil.
Es muy difícil. Pero yo creo que es un futbolista muy valorado…
Pero claro, hay que verlo también en el bordo. Yo tengo uno infravalorado por la crítica,
pero muy valorado por el fantasy. Uy.
Danos alguna pista más. Es capitán de su equipo.
Y central. Sí.
Antonio Rayo. Pero ¿quién es infravalorado por la crítica?
O sea, yo creo que Antonio Rayo tiene… Ah, sí.
Sí, en general. Vale, no.
El fantasy lo tiene muy bien valorado, pero que a nivel de…
No, crea que te especializas y digas que es Rayo en mayor ocasión.
Pero si no te has cansado de repetir que no por su afición,
no por la gente que lo sigue… No, no.
Por eso, por eso. Estoy de acuerdo que te ha entendido mal.
No, no. Por eso. Antonio Rayo…
Yo lo tengo aquí. … es muy claro.
Fue unista… Yo creo que como también hace una labor poco vistosa
y además es un defensa muy de antigua usanza,
yo creo que por esto no se le da el mérito que tiene.
Fue el año pasado cuando en alguna convocatoria dijimos,
a ver, a nosotros Rayo nos encaja, ¿qué pasa?
Que el modelo de juego de la selección es muy complejo.
Que esto ahora mismo me pasa con César Tárrega.
Sí. Que no sé si está infravalorado,
pues acaba de… Realmente ya un año en primera.
Pero me pasa lo mismo. ¿Tárrega podría ir por nivel a la selección?
Pues yo creo que sí. Perfectamente.
Pero el perfil no encaja del todo. Porque es el perfil de Dani Vivian,
pero Vivian ha aprendido a hacer más cosas con balón.
Vivian ha crecido en ese sentido. Incluso siendo ese perfil,
Vivian creo que es un jugador que sufre menos cayendo a la banda,
que es más capaz a campo abierto. Y aún así, el perfil de Vivian
juega en su contra. Sí.
También, también. Sí, sí. Que ya está más asentado en ese sentido.
Sigo yo con más nombres. Tú el nombre del lateral antes de que te lo pise.
Del lateral. La central.
Naguel Tenaglia. Sí, sí.
Es que este es de Manuel. Naguel Tenaglia.
Sí. Ídolo de Vitoria.
Recordemos, central de formación… Lo que pasa es que no tiene cuerpo central.
No tiene cuerpo de onda. Pero tú le ves jugar luego.
A nosotros que no sé cuántos despejes lleva en este Comienzo de Liga,
pero creo que promediaba seis o siete despejes por partida siendo…
Sí, sí. No de un mico, pero vamos.
Y un competidor como la Copa de un Pino. El tipo no va a un balón por perdido nunca.
Me parece infravalorado porque tuve los partidos… Es que también me parece que
aquí tenemos mucha culpa los medios de comunicación porque cuando el Atlético
de Madrid de turno… Lo digo porque es el último ejemplo. Empata en Mendizorroza contra el Aves.
Esco. Todo se centra.
Uy, qué mal Simeone. Uy, qué mal Julián. Y nunca se habla de los méritos contraídos.
A mí me cabrea muchísimo. Como si los de enfrente son de palo.
Tenalia fuerza un penalti, Tenalia está muy bien… Sí, el Atlético de Madrid
juega un mal partido, pero él a la vez juega uno muy bueno.
Entonces, claro, como no se valora ese tipo de futbolista ni siquiera en ese contexto…
Eso ha pasado en las tres jornadas de Atlético de Madrid.
Precisamente. Que el analysis ha sido más oye,
¿qué está haciendo el Cholo? ¿Qué no sé qué? ¿Qué ha hecho el equipo rival?
No se valoró a Fengroover, no se valoró a Kike García cuando entra o a Expósito…
Por cierto, no sé si en vuestras listas, pero creo que es complicado que me damos a
jugadores de los tres recién ascendidos. Al final estamos…
Sí. … punto digiriendo la
expectadía que hay en torno a ellos. Yo busqué alguno porque hay alguno que
puede llevar tiempo. Por ejemplo, tú podrías hablar, no que sé, de Andrés Silva,
por ejemplo, pero no encontré el caso yo tampoco.
Os traigo un debate. A ver.
¿Quién creéis que es el portero más infravalorado de la Liga? Yo tengo un candidato.
A ver, espera, espera. Sí, déjame ver la lista de…
Creo que es complicado, que en general… Infravalorado.
… que son tan poquitos los porteros que hay que es muy complejo.
Pero yo tengo mi candidato. Hombre, si es de Nahuel…
Sí, yo también lo diría. Augusto.
No, yo creo que de Augusto hablamos mucho. Y yo creo que la gente habla mucho también.
Sí, es otro. ¿Soria?
No, a mí Soria no es un portero que me gusta mucho.
Sí, no te gusta. No. Creo que es una posición…
¿Dimitrovic? Pues…
No, Dimitrovic tampoco me gusta. No, de hecho, le gusta mucho.
Por eso digo yo estoy aquí. ¿Postras? No, no…
¿Sibera? Sibera.
Sibera es clarísimo. Creo que…
Hablamos poco de los porteros en general. Esto es una maldición que arrastramos los porteros.
Sí, tú y yo lo entendemos, Nahuel. Sí.
Los dos de la misma manera, además.
Y creo que Sibera… Perdón.
He notado ahí…
¿Cuánto hace que no juegas un partido de porteros? Por simple curiosidad, eh, Miguel.
Tiempo. Igual diez años.
No. Sí.
¿Diez años? No, que va.
Yo creo que de los últimos partidos que juegue portero en un equipo hace…
Estamos en 2009, Miguel. Hace diez tenías 25.
Seis. Seis años.
¿Y no has tenido el picorcito de volver?
He jugado un partido, alguna pachanguita…
Eje, si se tira ahora…
…pa' levantarse.
Yo nunca me he tirado, además.
Es un saco de patatas.
Ya entendí ahora.
Yo era un portero que hablaba mucho, echaba la bronca…
¿Tenía bien eso? Eso es perfecto. Vamos.
Eso…
¿Qué tal el saque?
¿El saque de mano o de pie?
En corto. En corto siempre.
De chaval me sacaba un central.
Es que… Sí, sí.
Bueno, Sibera creo que, sobre todo bajo palos,
súper elástico, súper ágil.
Tiene algún problema más por arriba, pero creo que…
Con todo lo que se ha movido en las porterías este año en España,
ha sonado poco para salir de la laves.
Es un poco…
En su día estaba Pacheco, ¿no?
De hecho era un portero que podía haber sido
candidato a selección, incluso.
El año pasado, antes de la lesión,
yo creo que estaba a un nivel.
A mí me cuadraba mucho. Es canterano de Valencia
y me cuadraba para la portería de Valencia.
Me parece raro que no hayan…
No sé si lo han terminado de intentar,
pero bueno… Yo tengo uno.
Eh…
Es que tengo aquí como un cajón de sastre
de decir ¿son infravalorados o…?
La que se viene. Vosotros me hais la…
Yo no voy a disparar donde decís, ¿vale?
Aymar Oroz. No.
Rubén García. No.
Sí. ¡Mmm!
Yo lo he pensado meter. No lo he metido, pero…
Pero también lo de antes. Juegador de rol.
Eh… Como jugador de rol…
Es un poco caso rival para mí.
Pero yo he pensado meterlo.
Samu Costa. Sí.
No.
¿Ves? Es que hay… Para mí sí.
Para mí sí. Para mí sí.
Porque además de Samu Costa solo se destaca lo que hace
defensivamente. Sí. Y no con pelota.
Y con balón. Yo he bastante asidado.
Yo creo que sí. Es verdad. Más convencido.
Y luego me han hecho llegar por Twitter
aquí Omar Elgilali. Sí.
Debutante de la defensa de Marrocos. Sí.
Sí. Para mí sí. Sí. Es verdad que
este es un poco caso que he citado antes.
Que solo llevo un año. Eh…
Eh… Realmente en primera.
Porque es verdad que está en el… Tárrega.
Que todavía
podemos darlo por normal, pero es
para mí a nivel
defensivo uno de los grandes especialistas.
Sí. Sí. Sí. Sí. Sí.
Sin duda. Eh… Yo tengo aquí un nombre
que creo que siempre hablamos de él
en estos términos. Y me sorprende que no lo hayáis
metido ninguno. Pero creo que es porque hablamos
demasiado de él. Eh…
Luis Milla. Oh sí. Claro.
Sí. Sí. Sí. Me parece que es verdad que es un
futbolista que desgraciadamente
ha habido momentos donde no ha tenido continuidad
física. Ese segundo año creo que es en Granada.
Eh… No tiene continuidad física.
Después de una primera temporada con Diego Martínez. Es espectacular.
Pero a mí es un jugador…
O sea… Porque no hay dinero
en la Liga española. Pero…
Es que al Sevilla ¿cuántos problemas
le arreglaría Luis Milla? Al Villarreal
ahora. De esta… Villarreal
me encajaría. En ese rol que estaban buscando
en un paro. De parejo. De tal.
Me encajaría Luis Milla.
Entonces… Luego, claro,
cuando ves partidos del Getafe de Bordalás
y ves… Juega el partido en el Pijuan de Milla y dices
no está infra-hombrado. Pero es que juega…
No digo que juegue siempre así.
Pero juega muy bien siempre. Que ves al Getafe
y Milla entra rápido por el ojo.
Hombre, a ver. Brillar por contraste.
El contraste es muy grande.
Eh… Hemos hablado mucho
del Villarreal antes, sino hemos hablado del Zarra.
Que para mí es uno de esos jugadores muy infravalorados.
Ayoce. Ayoce.
Es que sobre todo Ayoce…
Pero porque estaba fuera ¿no? Yo creo que quizá.
Sí, porque le ha faltado continuidad.
Yo creo que está
infravalorado David Silva en el fútbol español.
Con eso te dice todo. Bueno, pero
hay un poco de todo.
Porque ha estado fuera, porque ha estado lesionado.
Creo que Ayoce se valoran mucho
las cifras.
Pero no se le valora que es un jugador
técnicamente finísimo. Finísimo.
Sí, sí, sí. Y creo que es un
futbolista que no… En ese sentido
no desentonaría en los mejores equipos
de España y de Europa. No, desde luego.
Es que, si no me equivoco, su debut
en pre-Aivision se produce con el Betis.
Porque él se va del Tenedice muy pronto a Newcastle.
Sí, desde segunda además. Por eso, por eso.
Sí, claro. El Tenedice lleva unos cuantos años sin estar en primera, desgraciadamente.
Pero nos olvidamos en muchos debates
de Ayoce y…
Vamos, es un jugón en absoluto.
Sí, sí. Una pena…
Al final, oye, no le echamos en falta en la Eurocopa.
Pero la pinta de que a la Eurocopa
había llegado…
Como un tiro. Como un tiro.
Recuerdo. Tiene un partido de los amistosos previos.
Que es verdad que esos amistosos son un poquito…
Dinamarca o así. Puede ser.
No sé. Creo que es Andorra.
Por lo que se digo.
Andorra no es Dinamarca.
Pero muy, muy, muy bueno la Ayoce.
Eh…
¿Algún nombre más que tengáis ahí?
Yo tengo uno que está en Vías de
Explotar y creo que por eso no lo hemos valorado
a su justa medida, que es Roberto Fernández.
Que a mí me gusta mucho, pero…
No creo que esté infravalorado.
Creo que es un poco diferente. Creo que todavía a la gente…
Sí. No le termina de…
Sí, no lo ha visto lo suficiente.
Es que yo a Tárrega, a Omar
y a Roberto los metería en la categoría
desconocidos.
Sí. Para el público general.
Sí. Que todavía no ha dado
margen y…
Si dentro de un año siguen teniendo el mismo
estatus, ahí sí que ya me parecería
el tema de infravalorado.
Yo tengo otro del español que pensaba
que iba a decir Alex cuando ha dicho lo de
elegir a Ali, que parece muy bueno.
¿Otro español, el máximo goleador?
No. No, no. Es verdad que ha estado muy mermado
por las lesiones.
Edo Expósito. Edo Expósito.
Es que jugaba infravalorado. Ya cuando estaba en el Eibar
ya demostró que era un futbolista
a tener muy en cuenta.
¿Quién fue al alorado en la época del Eibar?
Iván Ramis. Defendiendo el campo abierto.
Salvo para Mendil Eibar. Defendiendo el círculo central.
Siempre decía, no, tengo un central, no es rápido,
no se mueve, es el mejor.
Y Coté. Sin Ramis no podemos… Bueno, pero a Coté…
A Coté le decía otras cosas. Al pobre Coté…
La oreja de Coté…
Cuando le da la plancha…
Ha escuchado cosas que…
Vale.
La idea de jugadores que en su día estaban infravalorados.
Un poco como eso.
Hombre, este es un ejercicio que podemos hacer…
Sí, a futuro. Al próximo parón.
Al próximo parón. Ningún nombre más
sobre la mesa. Bueno,
estos son los nuestros. Pizarritas.
Seguro que nos falta alguno. Y…
Y insisto. Es que esto tiene tanto de criterio
particular.
No hemos metido ningún recién ascendido
ni ninguno de los tres grandes. De arriba.
Ni de Madrid, Barça, Atlético y Madrid.
Pero vamos a decir un infravalorado
de Madrid, Barça y Atlético.
Siguiendo todos internacionales,
campeones… Claro. Pero…
Millonarios. Siempre hay alguno que nos puede…
Que alguno que nos puede parecer…
Vienen un cantro. Alguno que nos puede parecer
mejor que otro. Empezamos por el
Barcelona. Vigente campeón.
Del Barcelona.
Infravalorado. Ferran Torres.
Buena.
No, no, no. Buenísima.
Sobre todo en clave selección
española, tuve esa ferranca.
Pero metía un gol, metía otro.
Recuerda el de Serbia aquel.
Y luego ¿por qué va Ferran Torres?
Me…
El Barça puede tener alguno más.
Pedri. No, Pedri.
Eric. Eric García.
A ver, Pedri está infravalorado para que no le…
No, sí, sí. Infravalorado para que no le valora.
Es que, Álex, uno ya nunca sabe.
O sea, es que…
Llevas una semana a mi lado y ya estás desesperado.
Antes no estabas acostumbrado
a mirar a tu derecha.
Ahora se lo noto. Ahora…
No, no. Os lo noto a los… A Adri no.
Porque Adri me ve de frente. Pero vosotros dos no tenéis nada acostumbrado
que haya una persona en la esquina.
Sí. No. Eh… Yo…
Yo juego de memoria con… Cambiate a mi lado.
Parece España de Escarillo lo es.
Bueno.
Yo soy Ferran y Eric.
Eric es bueno. Es muy bueno.
Real Madrid.
A mí en su día me parecía Ferlan Mendí.
Porque Ferlan Mendí es
el biotipo de infravalorado.
Yo soy mucho de Valverde en este sentido también.
Yo te diría militao.
Militao y infravalorado.
No me da. No.
Su momento era el mejor. Sí, pero…
No, no. Tengo el de Madrid. Chua Mení.
Es que claro.
Es un poco tramposo decir esto ahora.
Pero… Infravalorado, no.
A ver, quiero decir… La gente se bajó del barco.
Lo más parecido…
No podía jugar en Madrid. No podía.
No podía. Había acabado su tumba ya.
Como central no podía.
No podía.
Es que no se me ocurre…
Sí. Yo creo que lo más parecido es Chua Mení.
Creo que ya…
El arco de redención está completado.
Es la sensación con Chua Mení.
No. Y todavía…
Todavía puede hacer dos meses horribles.
Sí. Pero que… Y que vuelvan a pedir
que no juegue en Real Madrid.
Que no puede ser. Y pitada.
Yo he visto jugar a redondo en ese centro del campo.
¿Cómo va a jugar Chua Mení?
No es mi vida. Lo otro tampoco.
Pero eso ya directamente no.
Yo he visto ahí al Canario García.
¿Cómo va a jugar Chua Mení?
A lo guardeo.
Atlético de Madrid. Aquí quizás…
Bueno, para mí, históricamente ha sido Koke.
Es el que iba a decir yo.
Pero claro, estamos diciendo
de infravalorado ahora.
Es que claro. ¿O Black?
No.
Es que aparte… Hay una cosa…
Muchísimas personas.
Pero, Adri, estamos bajando
el debate a lo más bajo.
A lo más bajo.
Al subsuelo.
Al subsuelo. Entonces,
en el subsuelo que haya ganado X Zamoras,
da igual.
Por ejemplo, yo con mis amigos… Yo he preguntado a mis amigos
¿quién ha ganado el último Zamora? No lo saben.
¿Quién ha ganado los últimos 20 Zamoras? No lo saben.
¿Dónde está Zamora?
Me ha encantado decirte.
A ver. Qué mala idea he tenido
abriendo esta ventanuca.
Atlético de Madrid.
Es como que yo le he ponido mucho pichaje.
No, Black. No. No puedo.
Yo que comprado, Black. No.
Ni de broma.
Otra temporada dices Koke Griezmann.
Que era un poquito Sota Caballero
y de esto. Es que los haters
infravaloran a Juliano. Yo creo que no.
Yo tampoco que este Juliano
infravalorado. Quizá puedes meter a Marco Llorente.
Tampoco es santo de mi devoción
Marco Llorente.
Complicado.
Es que además tampoco está la letrera en el punto
a mí me ha pasado.
Depende a quién pregunte.
Yo tengo la opinión de que para muchos
está muy infravalorado y para otros muy infravalorado.
Más de lo último que he aprendido.
Yo estoy más en el primer barco. A mí me pasaba mucho con
Samuelino. Pero claro, ya…
¿En qué estrella estará? Con la selección.
Difícil. Bueno, yo creo que
Koke ahí nos puede servir de tiro
a tablero más allá de que ya…
Yo te agarre. Yo creo que a O'Black no se le valora.
A Barrios. Tampoco.
Yo te digo que a O'Black no se le valora
como lo que es. No sé si la opinión general con Barrios
es tan parecida a la nuestra.
Nahuel Molina.
Juliano del Varejo.
Bueno, pizarritas. Estos son nuestros
infravalorados. Ya hablaremos de los
sobrevalorados cuando
tenemos tiempo para pensar. Es más complicado.
Nos hemos metido entrenador. Infravalorado.
Uf. A ver.
No se puede ocurrir esto antes
del programa. Perdón.
Yo lo tengo claro.
Bordalás. No.
Inigo. No. No.
Inigo la mayor. Inigo tiene mucha
presencia que Bordalás. Inigo.
Inigo Vale. Valverde.
Valverde es verdad. Siempre pasa
un poco por debajo. El chingurri es buena.
El chingurri es buena. El chingurri es buena.
Se le valoró muy poco lo de
ganar tantas ligas seguidas.
Estoy contento con la elección.
Bueno, ¿ya?
Pronto los sobrevalorados.